well i found this actually interesting
is it true that you
babysat bob saget's kids is that yes i
did
it's so random i know isn't that and
then he was the voice on how i met your
mother so
um yeah i was a teenager and at the time
like when i started he only had one
daughter and i remember that
um i was invited to her like third
birthday or something
and so there's a lot of three-year-olds
running around the olsen twins were
there
you know and they were about the same
age and uh and the parents decided they
all wanted like a group picture of all
the children and it's like
25 3 year olds good luck good luck so um
so everybody's trying to corral their
their sugared up child the olsen twins
like got put in their spots and they
stayed there for
what seemed like me to me like 20
minutes
and they just stood there while every
other parent was trying to like
around get and keep their child into and
i was like
they are professional wow yeah
my kids like for a billion dollars i
couldn't get them to
yeah i don't know if i could do that to
my kids now and they're like
almost 12 and nine i don't know i'm not
above bribery
yeah oh totally yeah i don't care
parents
judge me i don't care yep i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever